hey what's up guys my name is a Jenna
welcome to episode 78 of game
programming so we're gonna talk about
this whole particle thing here so a lot
of you guys pointed out that this was a
big flaw here and I'm glad you did
because that was partly well I mean I
just wanted to show you guys what I
meant here so what we could do my
original intention was to actually make
this static which of course changes the
entire scope of things because if it's
static that means that there's only one
instance of this particles ArrayList in
all of his in all of history okay so in
other words if we make this static that
means that there's only gonna be ever
one instance of this and here it is okay
that changes a lot of things but and and
we could develop that on woods there's
so many ways we could do this whole
particles thing but actually someone
mentioned a particle emitter object and
that really got me excited because I'm
like oh my god that's such a good idea
and I didn't think of that so we're
gonna go ahead and do that
um I should give credit should know I
this okay let me find that person who
suggested that right where are you
amid some some search control-f emitter
so there's one person who said it so Sam
brave Sam brave said it and as far as I
can see he's the guy who suggested it
yeah so Sam brave thank you to you for
suggesting this because this is an
awesome idea I'm gonna use it okay
so particle in fact we might just call
it a middle I'm thinking right now
because I think I might wanted to emit
other things instead not just particles
so let's pop that into entity let's just
pop that into entity not interparticle
okay and I'm thinking quickly let's say
do we wanna
have it for other things what else could
we omit though right I mean particles um
oh it could be like a spawner ha what if
it was like a spawner so this feels like
a live stream doesn't it entity like a
spawner kind of thing you know I mean
like it could spawn mobs it could spawn
anything really
emitter spawner I think I want to call
it spawner okay so now it's no longer
Sam gross idea I'm kidding
so this is essentially an emitter but
instead of calling it a particle emitter
I'm it's it can emit other things
instead of just particles right so this
spawn is basically going to be like the
parent of any entity so it is going to
be an entity in itself okay but what
spawner is going to have is an array
list of entities itself okay so private
list entity and C's essentially so the
spawner is almost like a group of
entities but what's gonna happen is
they're probably gonna come out at the
same time they're actually going to here
and be created at once okay it unknown
port that and cool okay so now that
we've made this entities thing let's
take a look at our projectile over here
sorry I don't projectile let me close
this stuff that we don't need let's take
a look at particle over here
right so we've got a private list of
particles we're gonna get rid of that
completely all we're gonna keep is a
life and the amount in fact we probably
don't need that at all in fact I might
even just delete this entire constructor
okay
can I hit ctrl shift or which will
basically just remove the import that
I'm not using and all that stuff and
import things that I need that I'm not
that I haven't imported yet but I've
seen in this case everything is imported
okay and so what's gonna happen here is
this stuff is all fine okay the updates
all right the rendering logic is awesome
and the actual this thing is indeed good
for one instance of the class itself so
that's great we don't need to touch this
at all right now
one thing I do want to do though is we
should really somehow the thing is we
want to remove this eventually but we
can't right now because we haven't I
don't think it has a valid reference of
level in it so you'll see an entity what
we have an entity is of this entity well
we have an our entity class is a an init
method which basically initializes
quote-on-quote initializes this entity
class and the way does that is
essentially by setting our current level
equal to or in other words setting our
level object here equal to our current
level so that we can use it throughout
our entire hierarchy here so level isn't
set in here we have to work out how to
do that somehow but more or less what I
want to do is let's see here so when we
make a spawner what we want is we want
an x and y coordinate on our map and we
probably want an entity for it to spawn
and and probably a and the amount of
entities we need to spawn okay so since
it is an entity we'll hit this dot X
equal to X this a wykel to Y now
entities how we handle this so yeah okay
so I'm just thinking so let's go for in
Eiffel 0 is less than amounts I plus
plus and now we have to think of a way
to actually make entities appear so the
way that I'm probably going to do that
is actually just use an enumeration so
that people can decide what kind of
entity they want to spawn so public enum
and I don't think we've used it in
numerators before so I'll explain that a
little bit um and we'll call it type I
guess and the types that will create are
probably well for now all we really need
is particle but for mobs I want people
to be able to spawn mobs as well we
haven't really made any a on any a I'm
so I will put more bandages for now as
like a placeholder and a leap article
minutes that's it okay
so what this does I don't even know if
we need the semicolon that I don't think
we do
but anyway what this what this basically
does is created a custom variable kind
of like an integer right but it creates
in fact this is pretty much an integer
because it maps these two integers but
the point is that creates custom
variable called type and the values of
type can be equal to the following okay
so it's like we're creating a custom
variable and these are all the possible
choices so it's pretty um it's pretty
simple and it's pretty versatile as well
so obviously since we've created this
variable now we need to actually create
you know we've created the variable type
now we need to actually create a
variable out of it so let's go ahead and
create a type called oh whoops call time
okay and now we're actually creating in
here and instead of entity a let's
actually put the type into here and of
course this is public so people will be
able to set that to whatever they want
and you'll see how that works in a
minute we don't need to make it static
to have it work okay so the deal with
this is in fact let me probably just
before I start typing this code here
we're going to be quite simple but
before I do that lets go into our level
and actually start spawning a few of
these so I'm going to open our level
class now over here in I believe we're
using I think we're just using this one
right let me preach that I'll just print
running and we'll save fum yeah okay
so prints running to the console so we
are using this constructor and not this
one so over here what I'll do is I'll
just add a new spawner essentially into
the level somewhere so I'll go ahead and
hit up new spawner now the player is at
if we go back to our game class our
player spawn is at 19 comma 62 okay so
that's times 16 because we have 16
inside sprites so our tall coordinate
here is 9
sixty-two let's maybe make a spawner at
1662 so it's just to the left of the
player so 16 times 16 times 16 and what
was it 62 times 16 okay and then we
obviously have to specify time so what
we can do is just type spawner
type dot particle and then the last one
is the amount so we'll make like 50 okay
and as you can see that's sort of how we
access enumeration so note that we don't
need to make it where name we don't need
to make it static or it or anything a
lot of people make these static just
because of the way that you know if we
wanted to access this from it from
anything else without having to call an
instance of the class yet we would have
to make it study but an enumeration
think of it as an inner class in fact if
you know about inner classes you
probably know a bit enumerations very
well but it's kind of like that right
you don't actually need to instantiate
class to access this enumeration in fact
when you compile this code when you
actually packaging it package it into a
jar Java actually um separates it into a
different file into a different class so
what it essentially does and I'll show
you really quickly but if we right click
on entity for example and hit new we can
choose enumeration and then we can
actually make it you know type for
example and you can see that we get
public in on type and then that's where
we type mob and particle okay and that's
what it is okay that's actually what the
compiler does for us but because we'll
only be using this in the spawner class
it just makes a bit more sense or not
and it just kind of cleans your
workspace a bit if we put it into the
actual spawner class so let's delete
that but that's how it works so that's
how the access to it sort of works so
now that we've specified the type
particle let's actually do something
about it let's go ahead and say that
let's first of all set they still type
equal to type I don't think we'll
actually need it but yeah we probably
warrant but just in case I will declare
Bavaria so for the amount okay let's
create new instances of this type so in
other words if our type is equal to type
dot particle and we actually need to
create a bunch of particles only so new
particle X wildlife of course would be
X&Y Nuttall life is questionable
okay the way that we specify the life
might be a bit different okay and this
is gonna be very subjective here because
it really depends on your opinions on
how you want to do this I'm Lou's gonna
pop 50 in there for now we'll talk about
that later how we can specify life
because of course life is something that
doesn't apply to a mob but does apply to
a particle so that's where we get sort
of I guess side trapped as in it doesn't
really become very universal so let's do
this for now so that that's great okay
what we'll do is create new particles at
that location
and that's all great okay we've created
a bunch of new particles but then I'll
assign to anything which means that
they're right there render method isn't
going to be run nothing's gonna happen
here right wrong okay what we need to do
is actually add these particles to the
level so we can do that by hitting up
level because it's called spawner does
it's an entity level add new particle
okay and that will ensure they do render
and they are actually added as separate
entities now it's a bit different than
what we did before which is where we had
a separate ArrayList we could of course
make a separate ArrayList just for
particles in level and then we could do
something like level add particle and
that would add it to that specific list
but you know there's not that I could
see a bunch of a bunch of reasons why
you would want to do that for example
maybe some effects aren't applied to
particles or you know you want to handle
them differently in fact I think I will
do it that way just because um just
because it just cuz of a number of
reasons so let's make a new because we
do have projectiles in a separate list
let's make a new one and you
realism and copier here and I'm gonna
call it particles or particle and I will
call the actual list particles equals
new ArrayList and of course [ __ ]
also the types who be a particle okay so
now that we've credit that instead of
actually having to make a different add
methods for a lot of things we could
simply detect what kind what type of
entity the users trying to add and add
it to a um to its specified list so in
other words what we could do is say if e
is an instance of a particle and of
course particle can be subclassed so
that will apply all particles when we
make future types in the future future
types in the future that is that is some
solid solid grandmother not a grandma
English but anyway hmm so if it is if it
is instance of a particle then of course
will it initialize it as well
in fact we probably just put that up in
the global thing because that will
happen no matter what but instead of
adding it to here right we're going to
actually add it into the particle list
so if E is an instance if the entity
that is supplied is an instance of a
particle then we can add it to the
particles list so particles add a ok
right okay and we need to cast it to a
particle force actually wait that
shouldn't even be happening because it
is a particle it sends entity oh yeah no
of course
because I've set them to be particle my
bad okay so we can cast a particle of
course this is absolutely safe because
we've checked if it is an instance of
that else we'll do that but also I want
to add one more here and that's an else
if so else if e is instance of a
projectile yeah then we can add it to
the real list which is what we've done
here okay but I'm gonna ship that up
literally here okay and change this to
eight and we will have to cast that to
be a projectile
okay and that removes the hunt I made
for this again really really cool and
really are really simple sweet so
obviously in the a projectile method in
our mob class here we need to change the
a projectile to be as simply an ad okay
and then the code will figure out what
type of entity it is and adders
accordingly so now that we've done this
let's not forget to actually add a
projectile our particles into the UM
into the level by adding the spawner so
add new spawner at that location okay
that's all we need to do now the new
spawn the spawner itself is an entity
okay and if you notice over here if you
notice in our little ad thing we're not
separating a spawner okay we'll just
keep the spawner as an all entity as we
would with a um a mop for example okay
so let's run this and see what happens
okay so we get a nice little crash here
because I probably forgot to do
something okay we've got a
nullpointerexception
that is interesting so let's get out of
this and the reason for
nullpointerexception and level is of
course because this init thing hasn't
run properly so let's go ahead and go
back to level and chance out so we do
create a new spawner and we do add it so
we should be initializing it and the
reason of course for this entire problem
is because we do initialize this here of
course but and that works obviously but
the problem here the big problem here is
that we're actually calling in the
constructor so what happens is of course
our code executes this constructor first
where are we our code executes this
constructor first right and it's trying
to add it to the level but it doesn't
actually exist yet okay the level isn't
specified yet so there are many ways to
work around this the best way to
probably do it is to simply add a level
into the constructor here so if you want
to make a spawner then you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to actually specify
a level so in this case we'll specify
this okay so let's go back over here
type in level level and then we can
simply in it this with level and it
doesn't matter if it gets initialized
again that's fine but the idea here is
that it will um it will know which level
to add this particle through ok let's go
ahead and start that up and what we
should see here is a bunch of particles
and we do not so as figure out why
that's happening so we seem to be adding
them here and that is type particle so
that's fine let's delete this ArrayList
first of all that doesn't need to be
here anymore and in fact the reason that
let's uh clear those imports the reason
that is probably not doing anything is
it because in level of course we did
actually create an extra array list here
called particles but we don't call that
anywhere so in update let's make sure
that we do actually update I should make
an ArrayList of ArrayList should know
that'll be a lot simpler
so particles dot size and let's update
them and those do exactly the same thing
in the render okay so you gotta remember
to do this stuff otherwise um you'll be
wondering why your code isn't working so
everything will change here is render
and we'll change that to screen ok so
let's try that out now and as you can
see our particles doing data PA yeah
again if I run the game again there they
are
okay now that might be a bit of an
awkward situation to add them in just
because of course as soon as we start
the game it kind of does this and that's
just us just a bit weird but what you'll
see over here if we go to spawner and
particle rather what we to do instead
for example let's get rid of all let's
get rid of rid of a bunch of this stuff
um how a minute where are we level okay
so what we'll actually do right now is
let's see if we can adjust the the
amount so if we set that to let's just
verify that we do indeed get two
particles one two awesome
let's change it to one we should get one
there it is one lonely particle and if
we change it to 500 well
you get 500 particles in news as you can
say we do okay so that is how that works
we'll talk a bit of a bit more about
actually using it to our advantage this
particle engineer thing here and also of
course this this solution isn't really
good it's only good if we're actually
well actually no it's fine because um
but the it is a bit limiting because we
do we can only hold this if we are
inside a class that has access to level
which is to be honest all the entities
so what we are specifying by doing this
is essentially saying oh okay only an
entity can spawn a spawner okay and that
might not be a hundred percent realistic
so we revisit revisit that next time but
otherwise I'll probably see you guys
tomorrow
with another with another episode on
actual um the life stuff because we
haven't covered life at all yet again so
hope you enjoyed this episode of game
programming pretty long one and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you